Nuclear tests must end to help ensure a safer world.
That was the message at United Nations headquarters on Thursday...
...at a special meeting of the General Assembly marking the International Day against Nuclear Tests.
In a video message to the gathering,...
...Secretary-General Ban Ki-moon remembers visiting Semipalatinsk,...
...once one of the world's largest nuclear test sites in Kazakhstan.
I visited the site two years ago.
I learned more about the terrible impact,...
...but also about how people are working together to restore the area...
...and improve the health of the people.
I came away with a feeling of hope for the future.
Nuclear tests are a threat to human health and global stability.
The effects are both harmful and long lasting.
As we mark this International Day against Nuclear Test,...
...let us strengthen our efforts to achieve the widely shared goal of a world free of nuclear weapons.